all right in all seriousness everyone
keeps asking uh
why
are we shutting the show down there's
basically three reasons right
the first is uh when we started this
show i committed to myself uh that i was
gonna do it for at least one year one
year i was going to do it
and a huge decision that i made last
year
was that i returned all uninvested
outside capital uh on the investing
business and i basically just said look
i don't give a [ __ ] about uh kind of
doing what other people want me to do
i'm going to do what i want to do
and it turned out to be a fantastic
decision
at the time i considered
to go ahead and stop doing the show as
well
but i committed to myself i was gonna do
it for one year and i felt that uh that
was important to keep uh keep doing
the second thing
is that there's a lot of folks who
complain
about the news the media the mainstream
media uh they like to point fingers and
say these people are idiots these people
don't understand what's going on in the
world
these people have no clue how to
communicate all that stuff
there's not very many people
who can now say that for a year
they built something similar
ran it and saw inside the belly of the
beast
the incentives are so [ __ ] up
it is so screwed up
the incentives go towards
clicks views all this type of stuff
it also a huge piece of it every single
person you see on twitter that's not
them every person you see on youtube for
the most part that's not them every
person that you end up watching on
somewhere on the internet that's not
them they become characters of
themselves
and for me i'm just not interested in it
i really don't care about the day-to-day
news stuff
i don't really
find a lot of uh kind of the the
tertiary conversations or
kind of the the everyday events super
interesting um and what the incentives
end up doing is they not only pull you
into a lot of nonsense but on top of
that uh it also takes somebody like
myself who my number one goal in life is
to learn and to just spend as much time
as i possibly can learning uh and it
pulls you out of the student role and it
puts you into the teacher role and
there's value to that and i talk to
people every single day who watch this
show
and what ends up occurring is uh they've
learned something they've got some value
out of the show and i appreciate that
and i'm glad that that's happened
but i don't want to be the teacher i
don't think that i've got all of the
information i don't want to be the
person who's looked at for the answers
instead i want to be
in the student role i want to be the one
who gets to ask the questions who gets
to learn who gets to seek out the most
interesting people the people who have
information i don't have and uh and go
and learn and so uh in some ways the
incentives and it's not just this show
it's not just mainstream media it's
every single other person in the bitcoin
community every single other person in
the crypto community and every single
other person in any other industry that
does something that is a daily show the
incentives are screwed up and they will
end up in the same place
it's because the incentives are off and
so naturally
me
shutting this down is me saying i'm not
gonna play that game right it's the
wrong game to play and i don't like
playing this game and so
if you can't change the incentives then
go do something else since that's what
we're doing here
and i think that naturally where you see
trust across society is people are not
trusting the mainstream media they're
not trusting news sources instead what
they're doing is they're going towards
longer form conversations like i have
done for years
and they're going towards people uh that
they get to know over time and so uh
we've been doing this now for i don't
know four years almost five years and so
that's what we're going to spend most of
our time doing is we're going to double
and triple down on the long form
conversations uh probably many of you
that's how you originally
found some of the content found myself
or found what we were talking about
and then lastly
is as many of you know
plain and i had a a daughter she's uh
eight months old and this is a huge time
commitment to do this every single day
uh we spend anywhere just on the
recordings two and a half to three hours
a day and that's just for the live video
most people don't realize there is
nobody make no doubt there is nobody in
the world who can keep up with me when
it comes to output
every single day for over a year
we have produced a written newsletter
that i write myself
two podcast episodes five youtube videos
a two-hour live stream and all the
social content and obviously the rest of
the team is incredibly helpful in terms
of uh producing that stuff editing it
all that type of stuff
but we don't get to create that content
unless i sit here and i record or i
write or i tweet or i post it and so
naturally that time commitment uh it's
fun i enjoy doing some of it but i want
to spend more time with pelina and i
want to spend more time with our
daughter and so when you kind of add all
that up between
an aspect of uh the incentives are off i
want to be the student not the teacher
and i want to
be more in control of my time i want to
be able to do what i want to do when i
want to do it i don't want to have to
say to a friend who says hey do you want
to come to this event do you want to
come do this thing hey do you want to
grab lunch oh sorry i can't do that
right and so naturally those three
things led to me saying to myself hey
let's shut down the live show and what
we're going to do is we're going to
still create tons of content you're
going to see
lots and lots of long form interviews
hour hour and a half two hours some of
them we've already recorded some of them
we have planned over the next couple of
weeks you're going to still see tons of
writing tweets videos all that type of
stuff but at the end of the day uh i
think that each one of you are watching
this if there's one thing i ask that you
take away from all this is just ask
yourself every day when you wake up do
you do the [ __ ] that you want to do or
do you do the [ __ ] that you think you're
supposed to do
and over time if you can keep doing more
and more the [ __ ] that you want to do
you live a much happier life and so
with that
i love you all
we will still post a [ __ ] ton of content
i hope that you continue to learn the
number one thing that you can do for us
watch the content share with your
friends
we will continue to do our best
i hope that you guys enjoy it
i love you
see you
you